جديده من المعتقلين من داخل قطاع غزه جرى
اعتقالهم خلال الحرب الدائره حاليا معظم
هؤلاء هم من سكان مدينه غزه ومنطقه الشمال
هذا واحد من هؤلاء الذين جرى الافراج عنهم
عبر معبر كرم ابو سالم تقلون مسكون شلحوني
كل اعيه خلونا يعني في
البكسر والدنيا سقعه سقعه
سقعه اجد شح
حملونا قالوا انت من حماس قلنا نحن مشين
حماس ولا تعين فتح ولا تعين اي حاجه احنا
مدنيين وقاعدين يعني زي زي الناس فيش
علينا اي حاجه احنا لو احنا احنا حماس
بقعد هنا يعني اخذونا من في الشحن ودونا
وين على البحر عند البحر جوره كبيره
نزلونا في الجره
الكبيره والسقعه بتخبط فينا خبط قلب
الواحد اج
يقف جابونا ايش زي البيض
هدول
البيض
ققول عن الكورونا
كورونا لبسناه مربطين كرش من
ورا كربين من برا بالحام بالحام احمام عند
حطونا في غرفه ذبح ذبح ذبح ض بعدين ودونا
عند شقه
الحصمه برضه ضرب ضرب ضرب عن الحسمه كل
نقليات اكثر واحد انتقلت راح مكانك انا
اسمي اسماعيل عبد العزيز اسماعيل ط سكان
غزه
الزيتون يركله داز بسموها انا كنت 20 يوم
تقريبا في مستشفى الشفاء لما الجيش هجم
على المستشفى الشفاء طلب من اللي بغص
يروحوا على الجنوب رحت على الجنوب انا
ومرتي وابني انت قالوي انا وابني وما
بعرفش انا بعد هيك ايش صار معي مع ابني
وانا هي وضع التعبان بالمره مستويه اذا حد
بعرف عن اهلي اي حاجه يطمنهم اني انا
فاينه المستشفى
ابو يوسف النجار على ما اطق مش قادر ن بسس
بده ينقطع بدهس الكلى اللي من يوم الاحد
ما غسلت وغير التعذيب اللي اخذته
انا للامانه ما بيعرفوش لا مريض ولا كبير
ولا لطيف كله بضرب كله
بنهان سحل وشبح وضرب صوره مصغره لما حدث
مع هؤلاء الاسرى هان الشاعر لقناه الجزيره
مدينه رفح يلا